i'm gonna be good lion  i mean i can see it i can see her future  when i close my eyes  feeling it all laid out in front of us  we're not gonna lose  [Music]  hey something wonderful is happening  tonight ladies i can feel it  come on give me a little walk let me  hear your wall oh man i'm trying to  focus your little roar lion  [Music]  [Music]  you owe me money you don't have i'm  offering you an opportunity  without a royale 400k  take it to this address by this time  next week  and lion stays home to god  you don't see me like a boxer to me what  do you mean  you haven't got that thing what thing  this thing  [Music]  i don't walk around going like this to  [Music]  people  i could kill you but i never get a  return on my investment  we got one option we fight  you use me from what i'm good at and  everybody knows it  you set me up  what am i gonna look out for you  [Music]  know what you're trying to do you don't  know why i do what i do  we're not gonna lose  you